[Music]
hi everyone welcome back to our podcast
and the series called High School
memories my name is dashir and I will be
your host today so without further Ado
let's dive in today's episode and embark
on a great journey together get ready to
be engaged undertak and inspired today's
topic will be about motivation
matters the podcast that recognize your
inner drive and help you achieve your
goals and in today's episode we'll
explore the power of motivation and how
it can Propel us toward
success so let's dive in motivation is
the inner spark that pushes us to take
action overcome obstacles and strive for
excellence is the fo that keeps us going
going when the going gets St but what
exactly is motivation and why it is so
important in our
lives at its cure motivation is a
combination of our desires beliefs and
values is the emotional drive that
compuls us to pursue our Dream set
challenging goals and persist in the
face of
adversity motivation is like fire within
us purpling us forward and is essential
for achieving personal and professional
success so how can we harness and
maintain motivation in our lives well
one key
factor is finding our why understanding
our purpose and the deeper reason behind
our goals can give us a strong sense of
motivation when we have a clear vision
of what we want to achieve and why it
matters to us it becomes easier to stay
focused and driving it's also crucial to
surround ourselves with positive
influence building a support system of
likeminded
individual who share our goals and
aspiration can provide us with
encouragement inspiration and
accountability whether it's join a
mastermind group seeking a mentor or
connecting with peers collaboration can
Fel our motivation and keep us on
track however motivation isn't immune to
challenges there will be times when we
Face setbacks self-doubt or a lack of
enthusiasm during this moment it's
essential to cultivate resilience and
self-belief remind yourself of Po
achievement practice
self-compassion and focus on progress
you've made so far remember motivation
is not a constant state but a renewable
resource that we can tap
into now let's explore some practical
strategies for busting motivation in
various areas of Our
Lives whether it's in our careers
relationship or personal development
motivation plays a visual
role in our professional lives finding
meaning and purpose in our work is Key
by aligning our professional goals with
our personal values we can create a
sense of fulfillment and passion
additionally breaking down complex tasks
into smaller achievable steps and
rewarding ourself along the way way can
help maintain
motivation so when it comes to
relationships motivation plays a
significant role in nurturing connection
and building strong
bonds by practicing active listening
expressing appreciation and setting
share goals we create an environment
that encourages both personal and
Collective growth
finally in the realm of personal
development motivation is the driving
force behind continues learning and
self-improvement embracing a growth
mindset seeking new
challenges and celebrating progress
rather than Perfection can f our
motivation to become the best version of
of
ourselves and as we conclude this
episode of motivation matters let's
remember that motivation is not uh one
size fits all
concept each of us has unique drivers
that sources of
inspiration what matters most is
uncovering what truly motivate us and
nurturing of the
flame
within here's one of my favorite
motivation message for you motivation is
the fire that ignites within you pushing
you to step out of your comfort zone
Embrace uncertainty and pursue your
aspirations with unwavering
determination knowing that each step
back is an opportunity for growth and
every small step forward brings you
closer to the extraordinary life you
deserve here's another motivation
message that I use to read every day and
I want to share with you in the face of
adversity remember that your dreams are
worth fighting
for with unwavering determination a
positive mindset and the willingness to
put in the offer you have the power to
turn challenges into stepping stones and
transform your insiration into a reality
that surpasses even your wildest
imagination and now I'm going to mention
some important people who have left
important messages you should follow the
first one but believe you can and you
are halfway there Theodor
roselt the second one the future belongs
to those who believe in the beauty of
their dreams Elanor roselt third one
Success is Not final failure is not
fatal it is the courage to continue that
count won
Churchill the fourth one do don't wash
the clock do what does keep going Sam
Lon fifth the only way to do great work
is to love what you do Steve Jobs
six believe in yourself and all what you
are know that there is something inside
you that is greater than any obstacle
Christian D lson seventh you are never
too old to set another goal or to dream
a new dream CS Lis
eight the only limit to our
realization of Tomorrow Will Be doubts
of today Franklin D
Roosevelt nine FAS is not the key of
happiness happiness is the key of
success if you love what you are doing
you will be
successful Albert
Scher 10 the future depends on what you
do today Mahatma
Gandhi I hope this episode has sparked
your motivation and provide you with
available insights remember motivation
is the key to unlocking your full
potential thank you so much for joining
us on this episode of high school
memories it's been an Incredible Journey
we are so glad you came along for this
ride until next time keep thriving keep
dreaming and keep your motivation
[Music]
alive
oh